Everyone will tell you that
cycling is good for you.
It's a great work out.
It's good for your heart and
lungs, as well as your legs.
Unless something like
this happens.
Accidents happen.
And when lorries or
cars are involved,
they can be very serious.
But the outcome is not
determined by luck or fate,
but by the laws of physics.
Since people aren't going to
stop riding bikes or driving
cars, then we need to use those
laws of physics to try
and prevent injuries.
You want to keep something
fragile, like my mobile phone
safe when you post it, a good
idea is to put it in a
polystyrene box.
Because any kinetic energy
coming from an impact gets
absorbed by the polystyrene,
which dissipates that energy
in terms of the defamation of
material, fracturing of the
material, heat, and as
you heard, sound.
So that's exactly what
cycle helmets are.
They're padding for your head.
They've got expanded polystyrene
packaging, and
they're designed to crush
and reduce the
energy of the impact.
Now, helmets are all tested to
stringent safety standards.
But the standard tests have to
be simple and reproducible,
and straightforward.
And in helmet cases, they're
basic to the point of perhaps
not representing a real
cycle accident.
One of the standard tests for
bicycle helmets is a drop from
a 2 metre height onto a flat
surface with a weighted head
inside the helmet.
Now, we don't have a weighted
head at the moment, so we'll
make do with something
a bit more fun.
So, let's see if our cycle
helmet tosses our test.
I'm afraid in some accidents,
the balloon doesn't survive.
Just goes to show you
that sometimes you
have to test reality.
So the ideal way of testing the
effectiveness of a helmet
will be a randomised
controlled trial.
You take people at random and
assign them to groups, either
with a helmet or without, and
then you make them have
accidents, and you see
which ones survive,
and which ones don't.
But that's not really ethical.
So the next best thing is to do
exactly that process, but
with a computer simulation.
You can build the laws of
physics into a computer.
You can make a model
of a person.
You can make a models
of a bicycle.
You can make a model of a
helmet, and then you can do
that experiment.
And you can repeat exactly the
same accident under exactly
the same conditions with
and without a helmet.
If we now look at the results
for what happened when a cycle
helmet wasn't being worn,
that's the red line.
And you can see the cycle helmet
has done exactly what
it should do.
It's dissipated the energy, so
that the acceleration peak
with the helmet, the green one
is much lower and broader.
And in fact, only just about
comes up to the 300 G limit
that's set in the CPSC cycle
helmet standard.
If you compare that to what
happened without the helmet,
you can see that there's an
enormous acceleration spike.
And that's the head hitting the
hard ground directly, with
no chance of dissipating
the energy.
By an ironic twist of fate, or
physics, if you like, I was
involved in an accident
in 2010.
And that was a fantastic
opportunity to do some research.
You have a lot of time in
hospital trying to work out
why you're injured
the way you.
Why you've broken your neck,
but your legs are fairly
undamaged, that sort of thing.
So once I got back to the
office, it was quite fun to
recreate the accident using
the simulation software.
And this is something
fairly similar to
what would have happened.
This is a rear impact with the
car doing 40 miles an hour.
And you can see.
It's quite lucky I don't
remember it.
So now I have a pretty good idea
of what happened to me,
and I'm absolutely confident
that my head helmet, in
sustaining all that damage meant
that I'm still alive.
So if you are involved in an
accident, the best chance of
saving your life is to
wear a cycle helmet.
And you won't catch me riding
a bike without one.
It's just physics.